des changements importants sont
apportées à la conduite avec les
facultés affaiblies par l'alcool ça va
entrer en vigueur dès demain et pas
juste l'alcool vous allez voir on
qualifie ça d'un majeur les corps
policiers auront plus de pouvoir pour
faire de la détection
parlons-en tout de suite avec roxane
hamelin qui est avocate criminaliste
bonjour madame hamelin
bon alors il semble y avoir des nouveaux
pouvoirs comme ceux qui sont données aux
policiers je pense tout de suite celui
où on dit que l'on pourra faire preuve
d'un dépistage devront nous devons
donner un échantillon d'haleine
même s'il ya pas de soupçons qui pèsent
sur nous est-ce que c'est incontestable
ce droit-là pouvoir que les policiers
auront donc dans tout le temps faim
vendeurs d'alcool sans être là raconte
retard et fait le consommer de l'alcool
le politically avec lui l'appareil pour
ordonner à la personne de s'y soumettre
et si la personne refuse c'est grâce aux
tunnels est effectivement le cas
d'autres qui entre en gare de demain
sont assurément attaqué au niveau de la
constitutionnalité des lettres mission
parce que ça porte atteinte à première
vue à des droits constitutionnels bon
quels sont les autres selon vous parce
que vous monsieur roux mentionne celui
là est ce que vous en voyez d'autres
exemples en arctique une modification
majeure et que actuellement la fois de
la personne qui est accusé d'avoir
conduit avec plus de 80 mg la famille
pour les terroristes pourront invoquer
un mauvais fonctionnement de l'appareil
ou des mauvaises manipulations
d'opérateurs de l'appareil peut soulever
un doute là dans le final cette partie
sera éliminé le dos n'est pas juste pour
les gens qui sont accusés a trait à
partir de cet instant mais également
pour tous les autres il a pour des gens
qui ont maculé avant n'expire on leur
préfère compter demain donc fonction là
que je vous décris on va en effet
rétrospective un sens si c'est assez
nouveau que ce soit rétroactive comme ça
passe généralement si on commet un crime
on connaît les peines plausible alors on
l'appelle rechange peut-être pas les
conditions vent tu te coup rétroactive
on voit si vous auriez pas du miel et la
cour suprême avait déterminé qu'il n'y
avait pas d'application rétrospective
des suspensions l'homme est un
footballeur législateur était demeuré
silencieux tandis que l'autre action
express on a prévu que ça tient tous les
doutes qui donc comme je suis ça vaut ce
que ça vaut aussi le coup sur coup
devant les tribunaux dans les prochains
mois banon mais pensez vous que la
légalisation du cannabis
et puis la détection la conduite au
volant en ayant pris du cannabis a pu
jouer un rôle dans toute cette
réorientation de certaines de ses règles
qui régissent nos notre conduite
mais je pense qu'on ne pourra éviter de
l'année à cause de la rigueur comme vous
tous cas natif de faire une réforme ont
tant au niveau du cannabis le pour être
sûr de nouvelles donc au niveau de
l'alcool donc on a profité des
changements pour apporter des
modifications des comme je vous dis
c'est en italie loin la bombe écoute et
on verra comment tout ça s'ajustera et
comment ce sera dans dans l'air du temps
alors madame à blaye merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
ils l'ont appris au revoir